>> Here are three options for measuring the variability using all data values.
One option is to find the average distance between any two data values. So, for
example, if you had a bunch of data values, you find the distance between each
one from each other, and then you take the average. Or find the average distance
between each data value and either the min or the max. So the distance between
these two, these two, these two, et cetera. Or you could use the min. So the
distance between those two and all of them, and then find the average. Or find
the average distance between each data value and the mean. So if this is the
mean, find the average distance between each one of them and that point. Which
of these do you think would be best?